here's how i prepare for my coding
interview i solve 1513 lead code
problems memorize all the answers read
cracking the coding interview five times
read elements of programming interviews
in all three languages python c plus
plus and spanish
the system's design interview don't
understand [ __ ] but memorize every
keyword sharding caching load balancing
damn i'm so smart go on linkedin to
stalk my interviewer check your facebook
check their twitter check your wife
nice
go on a glass start to find the
interview questions they ask
not good enough pay lots of money to
access a sketchy chinese website to get
leaked interview questions perfect i go
to the bathroom for my breathing
exercise
[ __ ] love meditating the company is
calling me for an interview i bring up
all my cheat sheets this is child's play
i'm ready for this
hey thanks so much for hopping on this
call you're welcome
um yeah okay um so i'm your interviewer
and uh yeah so the first question is
what would you do if you had a conflict
with your manager hashmap i'll use the
hashmap